[Musica]
[Applauso]
era il 19 luglio del 2000 era un momento
particolarmente felice della mia vita
perché mi ero appena laureato in
giurisprudenza e ho deciso come molti
fanno di festeggiare questo traguardo
la mia passione del viaggio e quindi
vado negli stati uniti arrivò in america
for lauderdale dove decidono di
ripassare anche l'inglese perché da lì a
poco
una volta tornato in italia avrei
cominciato a lavorare in uno studio di
diritto internazionale è una serata di
agosto il 29
sono le dieci di sera e devo andare a
bere una birra con andrea un ragazzo di
napoli che ho conosciuto nella stessa
scuola
percorro la sola la via principale di
farlo da una via con bar e ristoranti
locali svolto a sinistra passo un
piccolo ponticello d'ingresso e sono in
isle of venice una via privata
circondata dal mare una via dove tutto
era sicuro la sorveglianza il fatto che
l'entrata e l'uscita fossero uniche il
fatto che non ci fossero via di fuga a
parcheggio in fondo e vado a chiamare
andrea suono aspetto sono in ritardo per
cui lui si è già mosso da questa strada
e ritorno all'auto giro l'angolo e vedo
quattro persone con un passamontagna
mi fermo non faccio nulla uno mi guarda
mi urla qualcosa mi spara cadeau a terra
cade a terra e arrivano le ambulanze u
di vito di vip che è stato chi è stato
i paramedici continuano a chiedermi
questa cosa per tenermi sveglio mi
portano in ospedale sono ancora vigile
guardo negli occhi il chirurgo gli dico
non voglio morire mi aiuti le pallottole
scoprirò dopo hanno colpito il fegato il
polmone
e il midollo spinale stavo veramente
morendo passano 35 giorni di coma
indotto
mi risvegliano ma mi danno una notizia
sconvolgente non potrà più camminare
mi aspettavo un periodo difficilissimo
vengono importati in italia quattro mesi
di riabilitazione a vicenza in unità
spinale per imparare a spingere la mia
sedia a rotelle
cosa si può fare credo sia un nuovo
inizio per cui l'alternativa è solo una
pensare che sia la fine
infatti la mia prima domanda è stata ma
perché mi hanno sparato e la polizia
mice era il momento nel posto sbagliato
al momento sbagliato non erano dei
professionisti noi non li abbiamo mai
presi però vedi un ladro professionista
va dove ha tante possibilità di fuga non
dove le possibilità di farcela sono
pochissime questi ragazzi quello che
possiamo immaginare è che siano degli
sbandati
bella consolazione però io mi trovavo
con la mia vita stravolta con un
pensiero alla mattina che era identico
alla sera voglio ammazzarli in questa
situazione e mio padre mi dice ma perchè
non fai questo non fai quello non fai
quell'altro però io alla fine rifiutavo
tutto finché mi dice perché non torno in
barca a vela e la tua passione
sì certo ho sempre avuto la possibilità
la fortuna di vivere il mare con una
barca a vela
però ho pensato devo tornarci nuovi nomi
sulle ruote come briano e o sulle gambe
esisterà al mondo una barca che mi
permetta di far questo e non c'era
c'erano delle esperienze di vela e
disabilità con delle barche piccole ma
non c'era più la barca che mi avrebbe
consentito di tornare a una vita
precedente che sembrava assolutamente
non poter più tornare
e così avevamo la possibilità a rendermi
la realtà o plasmarla per raggiungere il
mio obiettivo
abbiamo trovato un cantiere italiano
mattia cecco e abbiamo cominciato a
costruire un catamarano un catamarano
perché non si inclina lateralmente
quindi con la carrozzina tu potevi
muoverti costruendolo però ci rendiamo
conto di come questa barca in realtà può
insegnare tante cose la barca diventa
più bella della barca del cantiere è
costruito normalmente allo stesso numero
di cabine e divani dove passo io passano
meglio tutti
ma allora perché in una città io non
posso muovermi perché quando vado a un
ristorante la mia domanda non è il pesce
sarà fresco mangerò bene ma la mia
domanda è sempre la stessa posso entrare
da solo e se mi serve posso usare un
bagno la risposta spesso e ci dispiace
non siamo attrezzati
ecco da questo stimolo continuo da
questo da queste difficoltà da queste
difficoltà
io dico dobbiamo fare qualcosa ma perché
se si può costruire una barca non si può
costruire una città dove tutti si
possono muovere meglio dove passo io una
mamma con un passeggino ha meno
difficoltà e così una persona anziana e
direi anche un bambino e quindi nel 2003
nasce lo spirito di stella che è il nome
del catamarano ma è anche il nome di
un'associazione onlus e dal 2003 al 2017
facciamo moltissimi progetti il primo
back to you e se voglio tornare miami
voglio tornare dove la mia vita è
cambiata lo voglio fare insieme ad altri
ragazzi disabili e insieme a grandi
velisti come giovanni soldini mauro
pelaschier
ma lo voglio fare anche per dire che
oggi purtroppo è più facile attraversare
l'oceano che muoversi a milano gli stadi
a rotelle io vorrei che questa cosa
cambiasse per cui da quel momento
abbiamo fatto tante battaglie abbiamo
portato 5 mila persone disabili in barca
a vela gratuitamente abbiamo portato il
messaggio dal mare alle università per
il segnale e progettisti a progettare in
una maniera più universale più utile per
tutti un concorso di idee dal titolo
emblematico pensare progettare per tutti
nel 2017
abbiamo pensato di fare un grande
viaggio un viaggio da miami fino a
venezia un viaggio con venti equipaggi
diversi perché 20 erano le soste le
tappe che noi abbiamo fatto persone
abili persone disabili militari civili
imprenditori di qualsiasi professione o
provenienza geografica
perché vedete nella barca e come nella
vita so che tutto è molto più complesso
e quindi se si litiga in barca e lì si è
ecco allora persone così diverse sono
riuscite non solo convivere ma a fare
una grande impresa perché perché avevamo
un obiettivo è questo obiettivo era
raccogliere dal segretario generale
dell'onu
la convenzione onu dei diritti delle
persone con disabilità ce l'ha
consegnata proprio antonio guterres e
questa convenzione ha attraversato
l'oceano
finché l'abbiamo portata a roma a papà
francesco
alla rai la ma chi ha tante
e a tante altre persone e ancora questa
convenzione viaggia con noi e ogni volta
che possiamo la raccontiamo ad esempio
in un'occasione come questa la
convinzione uno strumento importante lo
strumento che però va conosciuto vi
voglio mostrare un breve video che
racconta questo viaggio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
per me il viaggio poi ha avuto un
significato particolare perché in mezzo
all'oceano
ho sposato maria e wow è diventato
weddings on waves
[Applauso]
ma non è solo il mio viaggio in fondo ho
fatto pace con il destino
tanti anni fa sono felice faccio delle
cose che mi piacciono e che penso siano
utili ma il viaggio di tutte le persone
che hanno a cuore i diritti di ognuno
noi volevamo far capire che ci vuole
rispetto a questo mondo e rispettare
l'altro vuol dire alla fine rispettare
anche se stessi
vuol dire creare le condizioni perché la
società sia più equa ma vedete le
difficoltà poi hanno anche un vantaggio
a volte perché ci portano a ragionare in
maniera diversa perché ci fanno scoprire
nuove strade
se c'è un ostacolo noi dobbiamo pensare
al modo in cui lo possiamo superare
dobbiamo trovare dei nuovi modi
l'invenzione nasce da questo il
telecomando della televisione penso che
sia un oggetto che tutti noi conosciamo
molto bene è nato perché il suo
inventore della stufa di vedere l'amico
in sedia a rotelle che doveva dal divano
trasferirsi con fatica sulla sedia
raggiungere la mensola dove stava
appoggiato la televisione cambiare
canale e continuare così gli sms usato
nati in ambito militare
una volta che la telefonia mobile è
diventata comune servivano le persone
sorde il sistema di pagamento pos è nato
da un concorso di idee per il pagamento
elettronico dei non vedenti i tasti solo
tattili e una persona non vedente può
digitare sia il prezzo che il codice
crittografico è lui che più della
transazione nell'uso è uno strumento che
noi usiamo tutti i giorni e
probabilmente se chiedete una persona
non vedente neppure sa che è nato per
lui
ecco allora che si possono oggi creare
degli oggetti che sono veramente
universali
voi mi chiederete ma è tutto a posto le
ingiustizie sono finite
i diritti sono rispettati no però
abbiamo uno strumento è proprio la
convenzione onu dei diritti delle
persone con disabilità che abbiamo
custodito in questo lungo viaggio e che
ancora oggi come vi dicevo
prima ci accompagna dobbiamo però
conoscerla io vi chiedo diffondete
questo messaggio
[Applauso]
voi non potete farmi tornare a camminare
sicuramente però voi con il vostro
atteggiamento non parcheggiando in un
posto per disabili creando rampe dove
c'erano scalini creando nuovi
telecomandi creando ausili come questo
che mi permettono di muovermi in una
città di muovermi in una città vecchia
come sono tante città italiane
ecco voi potete non solo permettermi di
avere una vita piena e felice ma io
credo che facendo prevalere
l'uguaglianza il rispetto agli uni degli
altri erodendo quelle che sono inutili e
devastanti diversità contribuirete
creare una società migliore
grazie
[Applauso]